welcome back to Las Vegas now did you
hear Mr BBQ himself just moved to Vegas
and it is the premium all you can eat
Korean barbecue restaurant right here in
Chinatown now I did confirm with owner
Jenny here there is no Mister there's
just no two misses the missing and
misses two misses my mother and I okay
no explain what Mr barbecue is all about
what do you guys do so we're a premium
all you can eat Korean barbecue
um our difference of you know we're so
lucky to be here in Las Vegas it's our
second location we're lucky to have you
we love Chinatown and all the great
Asian restaurants for us it is a fun
Lively atmosphere with good drinks good
food
what really makes us Stand Out is the
quality of our proteins so all of our
beef is all USDA graded or wagyu and
then we do have a lot of pork Chicken
and Seafood options okay and so really
we just use the highest quality with the
highest quality service and the fun
atmosphere look very Vegas you guys
belong here and now this is what you
just said that's why people are lining
up at your locations back in California
we do have a little bit of a line yeah
okay so so what are they what are they
lining up for what's what's on the menu
um well Sherry right now she's cooking
these are the most too traditional
Korean barbecues that are marinated
right now is our marinated short ribs
it's a prime grade and then this on the
back is
um marinated
um Choice grade ribeye wow so it's very
traditional Korean this one's prugogi
and this one is called kaibi
um I think my mayonnaise come from my
grandmother and my mother and so the
marinades really are you won't be able
to find the taste it's our little secret
I love that and now your mom you grew up
in this business your mom had a Korean
barbecue spot when you were growing up
and now it's your turn yeah about 35
years of Korean barbecue experience wow
how have you made it different you know
what what's the customer experience in
your spot I think the thing is is we're
so you know it's all about the Asian
food right and so as long as you have
that food I kind of I come from a fine
dining background as well so I Encompass
everything with the Ambiance the
atmosphere the light and then really our
Our Guest interaction with ah with the
servers and we really make it a communal
really fun experience for everybody
absolutely and it's it's pretty
Cutthroat because it's first come first
serve yes okay it's just FYI okay so can
I taste a little stuff of course and
while I do that just let everybody know
how they can come visit you if you got a
website Instagram all of that
um so we do our um
like Rocky said we don't have
reservations but you can find us on Yelp
we're located right in the heart of
Chinatown on Spring Mountain Road and
Arville how is it oh
this is amazing
okay welcome to town Mr BBQ you guys
warm very warm welcome to you guys